lea y pedro empujaron dos mesas una
contra otra la figura de abajo nos
muestra el nuevo arreglo que tienen las
mesas cual es el perímetro de la nueva
figura así que aquí las tenemos
esta es la mesa número 1 y esta es la
mesa número 2 lean y pedro enfocaron las
mesas de esta manera tal vez porque
vayan a tener muchos invitados para un
desayuno lujoso así que decidieron
empujar las dos mesas una contra la otra
para tener más espacio para sentar a
todas las personas y nos preguntan cuál
es el perímetro de la nueva figura el
perímetro es la distancia del borde que
rodean a esta figura así que todo el
espacio alrededor de esta figura es el
perímetro y necesitamos averiguarlo
entonces lo que podemos decir es bueno
nosotros sabemos que aquí hay 3 metros y
le sumamos este otro metro de acá abajo
por lo tanto tenemos cuatro metros de
borde pero cuando llegamos aquí o no no
tenemos este lado y tampoco tenemos este
lado ni tampoco este lado ni tampoco
este lado entonces no podemos saber la
distancia total alrededor de la figura
porque no tenemos la distancia de esos
lados pero eso sí podemos encontrarlas
así que vamos a llenar esa información
como estas mesas son rectángulos
entonces los lados opuestos son iguales
entonces si este lado es de 1 metro el
lado opuesto también va a ser de un
metro y si este lado es de 3 metros el
lado opuesto va a ser también de 3
metros
y bueno por acá también si este lado es
de un metro
entonces el lado que está al interior
este lado que tenemos aquí al interior
también va a ser de 1 metro pero esto es
muy interesante porque la longitud que
tenemos aquí está al interior de la
por lo tanto esto no va a formar parte
del borde y eso quiere decir que no va a
formar parte del perímetro entonces este
metro no va a ser incluido en nuestro
perímetro y es muy importante que
nosotros entendamos el por qué por otra
parte en este lado de aquí y este lado
de aquí si forman parte de mi perímetro
así que es necesario saber qué longitud
tiene así que podemos decir que si este
lado entero vale 3 metros por lo tanto
este lado entero también vale 3 metros
pero uno de esos metros está en el
interior que es justo este de aquí
entonces tenemos tres metros de todo
esto tres metros de todo esto ya esto le
vamos a quitar un metro del interior
este metro de aquí y eso nos va a dar un
total de 2
metros de dos metros así que si sumamos
este lado y este lado me tienen que dar
una longitud de dos metros no podemos
estar completamente seguros de eso pero
vamos a escribir un metro y un metro en
cada pedazo porque al final lo
importante y de lo que sí estamos
seguros es de que la suma total de estos
dos lados tiene que ser igual a 2 metros
al combinarlos de nuevo en este metro de
aquí está al interior por lo tanto no lo
vamos a tomar en cuenta no va a ser
parte de nuestro perímetro pero nos
ayudó bastante a encontrar la longitud
de estos dos lados ok ahora que todo
está etiquetado entonces podemos
encontrar el perímetro que recuerda que
es la distancia del borde que rodea al
y va a ser lo mismo que sumar todos los
lados juntos así que si empezamos por
este lado voy a sumar de aquí un metro o
un metro ya esto le voy a sumar y ahora
vamos a ir hacia abajo y hacia abajo
tenemos tres metros tres metros ya esto
le voy a sumar y bueno para acá tenemos
otra distancia de un metro otra
distancia de un metro ya esto le vamos a
sumar y tenemos este nuevo metro que
acabamos de encontrar así que lo voy a
poner aquí un metro ya esto le voy a
sumar y aquí tenemos otros tres metros
otros tres metros que los voy a poner
aquí ya esto le voy a sumar un metro de
esto un metro más ya esto le voy a sumar
otros tres metros de aquí otros tres
metros de aquí ya casi acabamos ya esto
le voy a sumar este otro metro que
acabamos de encontrar también
este otro metro así que podemos sumar
todos estos lados para encontrar la
distancia total del borde exterior o el
perímetro así que si sumamos todo esto
me va a quedar uno más 3 es 4 +1 5 +1 6
+ 3 es 9 más uno es 10 más 3 es 13 + 1
es 14 así que el perímetro de la nueva
figura el cual es este arreglo que
tenemos aquí es de 14 metros y ya con
esto acabamos